bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors les talibans qui
frappent kaboul les y mènent des
attentats mais ce que ça veut dire
qu'une s'ils approchent et que peut-être
bientôt ils prendront le contrôle de la
ville
on en est pas là encore mais il ya dans
la stratégie talibans c'était une
stratégie en plusieurs étapes c'est à
dire prendre le contrôle des postes
frontières comme on l'a vu ces dernières
semaines parce que c'était aussi une
possibilité de prélever économiquement
les les le résultat ddd des douanes
et puis deuxièmement c'était
effectivement prend le contrôle de la
majorité des zones rurales et en
troisième lieu entouré les villes alors
là non dans le contenu des contre
offensives qui sont menées par l'armée
afghane et notamment par les forces
spéciales notamment vous évoquez lâche
kashgar dans le helmand au sud
c'est l'idée de pour les talibans de
montrer qu'il ya pas de sanctuaires
isation possible des villes qui sont
déjà infiltré dedans
même si le fait de prendre la ville en
tant que tel et c'est une autre affaire
parce que là il y aura des résistances
effectivement le gouvernement contrôle
les accents ton entend maintenir le
contrôle sur les grands axes routiers et
sur la protection des villes mais c'est
un message qui fait pas qui est passé
effectivement parle et aliments
notamment par son porte parole
zabihullah
mujahid pour montrer qu'il ya c'est le
début des représailles contre les
membres du gouvernement les responsables
gouvernementaux pour montrer qu'il ya
pas de lieu finalement sécurisé l'armée
régulière opposent une résistance on l'a
vu aux talibans mais les plus ou moins
faible tout le monde soit inquiet tant
de cette avancée des talibans mais
personnes fuient la norme devient l'aide
oui mais ça c'est le résultat
effectivement c'est ce qui était
signifiée par le président sera fera
miss et de résultat mécanique on va dire
du retrait acté effet quasiment
effectifs des forces occidentales et
notamment des américains même si les
américains ont apporté encore une aide
aérienne notamment aux alentours de
kandahar ce qui a fortement déplu aux
talibans parce qu'ils considéraient que
c'était une violation de l'accord qu'ils
avaient que les américains talibans qui
viole également la corde doit en
question parce que dans cet accord il y
avait une clause qui signifie de ne pas
investir des villes justement avant
d'avoir négocié enfin d'avoir finalisé à
une négociation avec le gouvernement de
kaboul
donc de toutes façons les j'allais dire
les dés sont pipés dès le départ et
s'explique le chaos actuel
alors est-ce que vu l'avancée des
taliban à ce que la prise de pouvoir des
talibans en afghanistan semble
inéluctable ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'une issue diplomatique est encore
possible en matière diplomatique on peut
on peut avoir beaucoup doutent
après la question c'est le rapport de
forces sur le terrain qui joue
effectivement aujourd'hui largement en
faveur des talibans
même si pour l'instant ils n'ont pris
aucune ville et l'enjeu fondamentalement
c'est ça est les talibans savent qu
investir les villes ça coûtera très cher
en sommes et des fois les quelques fois
où ici si on risque et ça a été
extrêmement coûteux d'où l'idée
d'asphyxier les bills en les entourant
effectivement l'empêchant de
ravitaillement mais on voit aussi qu'il
y avait quand même une
résistance au moins sociologique des
habitants débiles qui sont montés sur
les toits que ça soit à kaboul par
exemple on l'a vu dernièrement en
soutenant l'armée afghane parce que une
grande partie de la population ne
souhaite pas forcément évidemment la
prise du pouvoir par les talibans
on a vu les dégâts que peut provoquer la
multiplication des miliciens dans
certains pays est ce que c'est ça aussi
le risque en avril quand on a vu qu'il y
avait des miliciens pro gouvernementales
mais qui ne font pas partie
officiellement de l'armée régulière qui
dit contre ces talibans qui sont
vraiment ces groupes
ces groupes d'auto défense renvoie assez
largement à d'anciens chefs de guerre ce
qui qui avait été important au moment de
la guerre civile justement avant
l'arrivée des talibans en 1996 notamment
on peut évoquer le rôle à l'époque est
aujourd'hui de nouveau de ismael ran
autour des ratés d'ailleurs c'est vrai
que les chefs de guerre se plaignent que
la marge de manoeuvre qui leur est
laissée soit quand même contrainte
même si le gouvernement ne peut pas
faire l'économie de ces milices pour
aider l'armée afghane parce que l'armée
afghane
théoriquement ces trois cent mille
hommes mais en réalité il ya un noyau
dur des forces spéciales très efficace
mais l'ensemble de l'armée agave gamme
de l'est pas et donc ça explique
d'ailleurs que le président fera chra
franny et validé d'une certaine manière
le retour des milices d'autodéfense pour
lutter contre les talibans en soutien en
soutien à l'armée afghane qui est en
difficulté
alors justement parlé d'achraf rani on
l'a senti plutôt distant ans pendant
cette crise cette guerre ouverte avec
les talibans est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
apparaît encore comme l'homme politique
il faut pour rétablir la paix en
afghanistan
non il sait qu'il est de toute façon
politiquement il est condamné et le sait
même s'il peut pas le reconnaître
l'enjeu est pas tellement sur sa
personne et des idées sur la question
d'une transition et des modalités de
cette transition savoir s'il y aura un
monopole du pouvoir pour les talibans ou
si au contraire il y aura effectivement
la possibilité de
me trouver un modus vivendi ce qui pour
l'instant ne se profile pas tellement vu
la dynamique effectivement militaire des
talibans mais en terme en termes
politiques le président sera fera ni
c'est qu'il est totalement démonétisé
donc leur jeu et pas tellement sur sa
personne et il est sur la possibilité de
sauvegarder un minimum compte tenu du
retrait des occidentaux qui est acté
aujourd'hui david rigoulet roze merci
d'avoir répondu à la question vous
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue orient stratégique et